okay that's probably all right guys
Chris waters here on the GameSpot stage
still Sam from IndieCade still sitting
in here where as we take a look at some
more awesome indie games featured
through the indie games showcase
IndieCade showcase here at e3 on the
couch now we've got it zero from day
trip on games and zyb up from pop
cannibal and you guys are here to show
off a whole new game that has like a
really evocative and stirring title sure
we are sure we're here to show off elegy
for a dead were all OG for a dead world
there's a game in which you are a writer
and the conceit of the game is you
explore long dead civilizations based on
the works of British romance era poets
and then you write about them oh okay so
oh so you find the source material in
like Xanadu or something like that so we
got three well - what - talk about the
source materials Keats and Byron and
they each wrote these really moving
poems about end times the end of the
world they're on their lives so we get
this real good brooding feel that wears
man's place on earth and it really sets
the tone for writing yeah rough beast
slouches all that you know your stuff
what I know one or two things that I can
make that can reference in a pinch you
guys just provided me at the perfect
opportunity thank you all right so we're
taking a look here at elegy for a dead
world and set the stage for us I but
where are we at so you walk along you
observe what I you will want to perceive
or imagine was the story of this place
mm-hmm and to help people out when you
first get started we have what we're
calling prompts you sort of story
fragments it's like an advanced mad libs
at first because giving someone a blank
page is terrifying and insulting like
here's a piece of paper write me a story
I thought that was your job
you're the developers so we are gonna
give you a start something to get your
mind going in so here 50,000 years ago
long before blank this line is home to
great people uh-huh long before what
this is the sunset yes like that I mean
I don't know if it was the orange sky or
the so we're halfway on the way to our
Nobel Prize for Literature
so travel through and that was the first
of 14 prompts here
and you can fly a little as you are a
space traveler and you go from prompt to
prompt developing your story and
investing the more decisions you make
more invested you are in the world and
the more you're gonna you get halfway
through and often players will have a
strong idea of the world and they'll
start to be like oh this guy's prompt is
all wrong I know the next one should
actually be and that's why you can just
erase the prompts and write you know
whatever you want no kidding
all right so whatever fir know I thought
was an order had a poetical casualness
to it I liked it I you're writing you're
sort of that prompts you to move through
see the landscapes sort of do this
shifting and I imagine you know on the
ìiî state show hearing game audio isn't
really something we get to do but I
imagine there's there's some audio going
on that the folks at home are watching
yeah sure of some gorgeous atmospheric
stuff right yeah we wanted to keep it
very light because it's very easy to
overwhelm the player right you're
exploring this civilization that's just
dead and you're writing about it so we
wanted something smooth and Rhoni and
maybe a little eerie something to sort
of you know be a little background set a
little background tone well Sam I gotta
say I can see immediately why you guys
were intrigued with this synopsis that
you've received for this game and
decided to give it a closer look exactly
so have you played it yourself and have
you written your way through some ten
worlds played one of the levels which I
did when we were reviewing it for games
again you actually got it exactly right
when we were deciding which ones to look
at it was the synopsis write your way
through a dead world we were like oh we
should look at that a little bit more
yeah it's a really up for me atmospheric
and movie and experience what I ended up
finding is that the thing that really
made us decide to show in after evening
Citroen is it's incredibly beautiful to
look at the music really is sort of
moving and the atmosphere is very strong
and it evoked feelings in me which again
like lots of things about feelings and
us right but this is something that I'm
very interested in happening in games
and this is a vocation of mood of
feeling of ideas and what I found is
very much looks i but was talking about
is that I would write I would sort of
fill in the prompts and then after the
first three or four I was like okay now
I'm like inspired I have a story about
this world inside me and I can start
getting it out you get a little bit of
momentum yourself not just as you know
as the player and as a player and as a
writer and even if I don't know how how
often you identify yourself as a writer
but you know we've all we've all got
that kind of expression in us
yeah and is that what you're kind of
trying to tease out here we want the
most important thing is that someone
sits down and has a positive experience
doing something creative so we we really
avoid doing any sort of scoring or any
kind of hand slapping because writing is
can be personal and frightening enough
without attaching a score or anything
negative to it are you talking about
GameSpot's review process because it
really sounds like you are it's
resonating deeply with me right now well
as long as you give us a hundred then
we're fine we rate on a scale of ten
thank you it's rubbish Asst I like it
so now you've been you sort of ducked
inside there and you came out and these
feathers have been scrolling below and
those are the problems right but you can
choose to engage them or not right
so that's why did why you know what is
that what kind of feeling does that
convey to the player if they can choose
to do that or they can choose to just be
doing other stuff exploring etc etc most
players that I've seen play this they
approach it and they immediately feel
out of their element because they
haven't done anything before and when
they see worse obstruction that says
something I don't hear so you can write
people will stop at every one and write
and so we actually giving liberties to
players is something that they aren't
abusing because they're they're sort of
tepidly waiting into it and they'll
understand it once they understand it we
want them to feel like it is their page
to write on we have a mode where there
are no pre-made prompts there's no
feathers and you can write anywhere and
that's for their professionals and the
people who people come to us and like I
write for a living I'm going with this
mode I've seen them sit down and you
know write you know three pages at every
stop they go no kid now so it almost
almost letting players use it as yeah
like it a tool to avoid writer's block
just a just a creative endeavor
outside of the whole you know even the
fiction of these worlds in this place
that you've created yeah that's
fascinating I gosh it's really
intriguing and so now we're looking at
we've been looking at this one world and
you said there are three what what what
was the inspiration you know for you
yourself to pick to tease these worlds
out of these works of literature and
then to you know basically enter into
this agreement with the player where you
the developer have done some creating
but you are also saying you got it you
got to come here and create with me all
right
yeah well the chair and I we sat down at
the beginning trying to just do
something really quick right and we drew
out on these sheets of paper our
interpretations of these poems and
terrible scrawls we took them to the
kitchen great we showed them to ya a
colleague of ours Eric has smooth f82
apps and so we actually sat down and
saipa said look we're doing a game about
writing and reading
let's do dead romance era poets which i
okay that sounds good
and so we tear a lot of them they're
well they're all dead now yeah
so as ibis said we took them down and we
put them down on paper and we scrawled
and we said to our colleague can you
tell what the story of all this is based
on what what we wrote and what was
fascinating about it is that we took for
example Ozymandias the poem you know you
find a statue in the desert of a guy who
was like hey i'm all that but he really
isn't all that because his statue is
dead in the desert and we wrote that out
on paper as an imagery and our colleague
interpreted that and created an entirely
different story and we thought that was
fascinating and powerful mm-hmm and
that's it's interesting that you sort of
there's a couple layers of
interpretation happening there right
between you know you and the poem and
your colleague do you guys have any way
in elegy for dead world to to share or
to invite other players into your your
sort of experience well everything is
actually in Steamworks so when you
upload a story the end it's a Steam
Workshop item and therefore your steam
identity is attached to it and all the
tools for commenting and discussing and
sharing those items are available to you
interesting and
so but that's not you know someone
downloading that item and seeing the
story I wrote out necessarily right well
so in steam you have the option to go in
the menu and say add this to the list of
items just like if you're playing portal
you're like I want this extra level you
select it through their menus you go
back to your game and it is there for
you yeah so if you go say to your you
know your friends playing it you can see
in their workshop items they have these
stories that go yeah this one in this
one you go back into the game now your
friends items are there it's a really a
matter of just sharing stories if you
okay so it really does actually share so
I could read it Sheroes story and as I'm
going through it would sort of
illuminate as well very interesting we
have a whole separate reading mode where
we actually show the stories are written
in a sort of a stylized fashion with
whatever shader effects we can muster up
to you know give you a sexy page-by-page
here's some take a graphic novel a
graphic novel something a big text in a
background b which i think is pretty
sexy artist we got it's pretty sexy i
mean yeah this art is lovely for certain
and i can you give us a hint of sort of
some of the other aesthetics in other
areas before we before we wrap up here
yeah so we actually have a kiosk or
sorry exit kiosk mode so he the secret
heats world my my favorite poem of the
ones in here and this is Keats was
writing about the end of his life and
wanting to capture everything that was
there so this is a world that is very
actually constructed and it informed
more by the people made there in a very
intentional we have designed this world
type of way but as you pass through
you'll see the world break down and see
the creator's failure to complete his
mission and that's that it's a separate
sad feeling than our previous one well
it seems like I mean elegy for a dead
world certainly a fascinating way to use
games as a way to use that interactive
medium to delve into emotion like this
to delve into the creative act of
writing and the expressive act of
writing thank you guys so much for
coming on and sharing this with us thank
you and you said it was on steam soon
soon on steam and I'm gonna be part of
the indicate showcase festival later
this year
maybe so the way it works is the stuffin
III is all still being considered oh
okay a bunch of it could be in any game
festival none of it could be
the decayed festival and I can't say one
way the end all right well speaking
specifically for elegy for a dead world
where can folks follow for more
information on that all right you can go
from the deja bond website that's de jo
p aan calm all right that's where to
check that out and for IndieCade in
people people want to keep track of
submissions and check out games that you
guys are considering
yeah just our websites IndieCade comm
it's got a database of every game we've
ever shown in the past and as we start
to announce stuff for the festival it
all go up there excellent well Sam
Ichiro's I thank you guys so much for
coming on and showing off this beautiful
game here at e3 it's been a pleasure
thank you thank you thank you
alright ladies and gentlemen we are
nearing the end of game spots live
coverage from the e3 stage show floor
situation here in 2014
we've got one more demo to come up here
it's going to be very colorful and very
fun so stick around for that and then
it's up to the GameSpot war room for the
rap show to wrap it all up don't go away